do you still never watch Barbie I refuse
why there's so many different I know why
I know why no I don't don't don't put
this out don't even do this don't even
do whatever you're doing simu what SE no
no no who's simu seeu is the other Ken
no I read for it a bunch of times I
remember yeah so I didn't get it and you
know what makes that even sadder is that
literally everyone is on it even Adam
Ray
[Music]
the burns do you feel the burn okay you
feel good no I I know I know exactly
yeah I don't want to hurt you in that
way you didn't hurt me it just gets to a
point where you know it just gets to a
point where you start reading for all
you know they come over they give you
like this form you the sign right so
it's like a secret I've had many of
those like you can't even talk about it
and then when you get the script it just
says your name all over it like across
it oh that's right right so that they
know that if you put it online it's you
that did it right so I write it I I sign
it I work on it I do it and I just never
get it I mean don't say never get it
it's just Barbie it's one movie no that
and it's the seus in uh the Chang cha CH
yeah yeah Chang cha I didn't get that
it's fine I'm not being bit it's it's
it's the life of an actor you read you
don't get it some things I do get that's
my point I just don't want to it I don't
think you and Simo are going out for the
same role I'm not talking about Sim I
don't even know the guy he's great yeah
he's like he's hot I get it yeah I get
we're not I'm not he's the best seu is
one of my favorites no but you're like a
different kind of great yeah fat ugly
weird I get it you're great yeah yeah
yeah I'm not I don't even want to bring
this don't even put this out there it
makes me look bitter I'm not bitter I
feel great I'm exactly where I'm
supposed to be yeah ramas ramas R rust r
r r r does pop pop the thoughts um yeah
but I just you know is there like that
that Godzilla minus once looks good but
is there any movies you're excited to
watch yes what and you guys totally
ignored me the last time the boy and the
Heron never heard of it what's that I'm
ignoring you now T Bo is ha miyazaki's
new film it comes out December 8th and I
invited everyone to go on a field trip
with me and no one took the bait where
is it at the theater well there's a
there's I want to watch the subtitled
version so I have to look for that but
the cast of the English one is Robert
patson um they have like a pretty
incredible cast but I'm going to watch a
subtitles one I like I want the subtitle
I want the Japanese version yeah me too
yeah yeah it was supposed to be his last
movie but then he announced that he was
going to do another one yeah which is
kind of weird it's like he retired and
then very quickly he was like just
kidding yeah sometimes they do that is
do do actors and comedians like
outwardly say they they're
retiring let me guess
no I've never I don't know a comic
that's ever said I'm
retiring they just are forced to retire
yeah but what does that look like do
they do you think there's a thought in
their head like this is my last set
right here and I think I'm done like I I
mean but look at Mike binder okay binder
in in the 80s was on The Tonight Show he
did a bunch and one day he just woke up
and said I'm not doing this anymore and
he never went up again he did until 30
years later W he's doing it again now
and he's loving it Jud did that app he
didn't he was a comic
young made it as a writer stop doing it
but it always calls you back it's one of
those things where it's
like it's it's a
drug yeah but that's like fighting right
like MMA and stuff when they hang up
their gloves and like and you can see
the the tears in their eyes and it's
like you've dedicated your entire
existence to this one thing and like who
are you without it I know do you think
you'll ever you'll have that moment with
yourself yeah I know who I want to be I
want to be a
farmer like I want to not a farmer but I
want to have like animals around me and
I want to learn how to
bake bake what no I think he I he really
loves the Great British Bake Off right
exactly I'm not lying here and I think
he'd be really good at it yeah I want to
bake I want to um use the soil and put
my hands in it I need it need the soil
with my hands and really get into the
dirt what would you grow oh all kinds of
stuff like um